[Música]
en el océano pacífico el energy observer
se cuela entre los petroleros del puerto
de long beach el contraste entre el
acero oxidado de los buques de carga y
el casco en paneles solares de este
catamarán eso es sobrecogedor
entonces hay varios tipos de paneles
solares la idea de este navío
laboratorio es probar un poco todo
tenemos paneles faciales con células
separadas para poder contar con
exposición al sol
al interior del navío
la tripulación francesa conducida por el
capitán e visto hoy en usar le da la
vuelta al mundo para probar la eficacia
de las diferentes energías renovables en
entornos extremos bueno es un mal día
hay nubosidad al 100% no hay sol
entonces no producimos nada en
fotovoltaico en este caso es que es
interesante contar con hidrógeno en sus
reservorios en caso de problema ponemos
en marcha nuestra pequeña pila este
catamarán produce hidrógeno verde
fabricado a partir de agua y
electricidad des carbonadas tales como
la eólica y la solar el hidrógeno verde
concentra todas sus esperanzas porque
permite resolver un rompecabezas
energético el almacenamiento de las
energías renovables
aquí almacenamos nuestros reservorios
entonces se toma un poco de espacio pero
menos volumen que las baterías
peso equivalente tenemos 8 veces más
energía con el hidrógeno que con las
baterías el energy observer navega en
autonomía total gracias a una cadena de
producción de hidrógeno integrada al
barco
esta es la electrólisis aquí rompemos la
molécula h2o la energía solar alimenta
la electrólisis que separa las moléculas
de hidrógeno y oxígeno en el agua de mar
luego el hidrógeno es almacenado y
transformado de nuevo en electricidad
gracias a una pila de combustible la
autonomía energética muestra que somos
capaces de hacerlo pero conservando
velocidades bajas es por ello que la
velocidad promedio de este navío es de 5
nudos es un poco el modelo de lo que
debemos hacer en la tierra debemos
ralentizar un poco para avanzar más
si california le apuesta al hidrógeno
verde para impulsar el desarrollo de las
energías renovables el hidrógeno azul
representa aún el 80 por ciento de su
consumo mucho menos costoso de producir
es extraído del gas natural y
descarbonizado captando las emisiones de
co2 en el 2016 el mar como obligas 250
mil euros para comprar uno de los
primeros vehículos de hidrógeno en venta
en california es silencioso todo muy
compacto en los vehículos de pila de
combustible así hay una aceleración muy
rápida pero no lo hago con frecuencia
porque ello arruina el hidrógeno
el estado cuenta hoy en día con 10.000
vehículos de hidrógeno en circulación es
el segundo parque más grande del mundo
para tanquear nos dirigimos a esta
estación el vehículo de marca y llega en
silencio como si resbalara sobre el
magadán
aquí no hay combustible sino hidrógeno
tiempo en la estación diez minutos
cuatro veces menos que una recarga
eléctrica barriendo el apartamento no
soy propietario entonces el hidrógeno es
más práctico para mí porque no puedo
cargar un vehículo eléctrico
departamento con una tanqueada de cinco
kilos mar que puede andar unos 500
kilómetros el doble de un vehículo
eléctrico pero el precio del combustible
sigue siendo costoso entre 12 y 15 euros
por kilo erc y entonces por una tanque
de entero 15 por 575 euros
california concentra el 90 por ciento de
las estaciones de hidrógeno de estados
unidos pero las 46 estaciones no son
suficientes para satisfacer la creciente
demanda esta mañana tan que 'no me di
cuenta de que la estación no cambiaba
por completo sin una buena estación
ración a un poco si totalmente cuando
los volúmenes bajan hay un límite de
combustible por vehículo la demanda
llegó muy rápido nosotros los
industriales del gas tratamos de
responder lo más rápido posible pero la
es más fuerte de lo que habíamos
previsto una frustración compartida por
muchos automovilistas tales como will
martín hace dos meses entregó su
vehículo eléctrico para pasarse a la
hidrógeno pero ese día no hay
combustible esto crea una angustia de
avería porque usted no sabe cuándo
tendrá combustible tuvimos días en los
que había que verificar en la aplicación
porque todas las estaciones en un radio
de 40 kilómetros estaban vacías piensa
devolver este vehículo que sorprendería
si aún no tengo el primero de junio tal
como para cualquier innovación su
desarrollo es peligroso
por ahora el hidrógeno es expedido por
camión pero el objetivo sería convertir
el gasoducto para transportar este
combustible a cualquier lugar
en algunos años california se volvió el
laboratorio del país de la movilidad con
hidrógeno
en el sur de los ángeles se encuentra el
primer centro de investigación sobre las
pilas de combustible porque el potencial
del hidrógeno reposa sobre todo en la
descarbonización del transporte pesado
tal como el flete o la aviación la pila
de combustible tiene la ventaja de
trancar más rápido de ser más ligeras lo
que permite transportar más pasajeros
para el flete u otro porque es más
ligero eso permite hacer distancias más
largas que una batería eléctrica en
cuanto a los costos de producción y
transporte sean dominados el hidrógeno
descarbonizado podría alimentar la casa
del futuro y una pila de combustible
reemplazar nuestra caldera el hidrógeno
será producido directamente en nuestra
casa y tendrán agua caliente es una
innovación que puede permitir
descarbonizar y reducir las emisiones de
co2 de las viviendas y lo que estudiamos
combinar la energía solar las baterías y
la pila de combustible para mezclar el
calor y la electricidad de manera más
eficaz que los solar y las baterías
horas
la cuenta regresiva ha sido lanzada
california debe combinar todas las
energías renovables para lograr alcanzar
el objetivo muy ambicioso establecido
por joe by de cero emisión de co2 de
aquí al 2050
[Música]